et vous avez raison laissez tomber cette
de Fred
on peut le dire et de faire vous
même des films sans lui enfin sans elle
je dirais vraiment bravo
j'accueille ici à Titeuf Fred et homard
Christophe Alévêque André Manoukian
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attends attends
c'est énorme c'est énorme
c'est magnifique bonsoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors on a bonsoir donc Omar vous êtes
dans nos jours heureux de Nakache et
tous les nano avec Jean-Paul Rouve et
vous êtes un bon acteur moi j'étais tout
à fait sidéré et vous avez raison de
laisser tomber cette de Fred ne
soit
et de faire vous-même des films sans lui
enfin sans elle je dirais vraiment bravo
merci beaucoup
depuis le temps que je peux voir en plus
c'est le pompier
c'est le pompier tout le monde qu'on
peut le dire
quand même il est encore plus beau
aujourd'hui
c'est normal
[Musique]
mais on va se retrouver sur Canal
c'est le bureau à côté je crois juste à
côté on est en train de superviser tu
vas avoir un super truc et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de Inna larditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu